herr präsident meine damen und herren es
war ein grund system wird porree dass
uns die bundeskanzlerin in einer
eigentlich monothematischen zeit vor
setzen wollte aber dann kam der tag an
dem alles anders wurde ja vor
bundeskanzlerin sie hat sich
entschuldigt und die verantwortung dafür
auf sich genommen aber das meine damen
und herren es nur die halbe wahrheit
16 ministerpräsidenten haben in einer
nachtsitzung offenbart wie weit sie von
den stimmungen und gefühlen der von
ihnen regierten entfernt sind
denn meine damen und herren es hätte
doch eine einem von ihnen auffallen
müssen was sie mit diesen oster blog
lockdown anrichten
dabei spreche ich gar nicht von den
rechtsproblemen doch spätestens seit die
menschen nach mallorca fliegen können
aber nicht nach scharbeutz fahren musste
klar sein welches echo sie auslösen und
das ihnen sogar die sonst zu handzahmen
kirchen die gefolgschaft verweigerten
beweis nur noch einmal wie weit weg sie
von diesen menschen sind und nun wird
auf allen kanälen besserung versprochen
aber besserung meine damen und herren
muss bedeuten dass sie vorher und nicht
nachher den bundestag und die parlamente
informieren und beteiligen sie tun das
doch auch wenn sie vor einem
europäischem rat hier eine
regierungserklärung abgeben
warum also nicht bei entscheidungen
die ganz unmittelbar in das leben der
menschen eingreifen was der östliche
mittelmeerraum für europa bedeutet so
war die ankündigung lässt sich weit er
auch noch danach kommunizieren meine
damen und herren die deutsche politik
folgt seinen vielen jahren verlässlich
eine muster es werden wünsche formuliert
man versucht in die tat umzusetzen
stellt regelmäßig fest dass sie sich
nicht erfüllen und wurden nutze ich dann
und 15 die kritiker
frau bundeskanzlerin auch die europa
politik folgt diesem muster und weswegen
als sie von misserfolg zu misserfolg
einer europäischen fiskalunion ist nicht
in unserem interesse
denn es wird einen schulden union sein
und da sind wir nicht alleine die das so
sehen
die eu ist unfähig impfstoff zu
beschaffen und das impfen in den
mitgliedsländern zu organisieren
der frühere britische premierminister
blair des vor kurzem sehr klug
ausgeführt warum sollte man der eu auf
die weit komplexere verwaltung der
europäischen finanzen anvertrauen
die lektion der korona krise heißt
zentralismus ist schwerfällig und
flexibel und wirkt chaotisch
die zentralisierung ist das gebot der
stunde
und dieses gebot verweist auf den
nationalstaat weshalb das impfen in
großbritannien israel selbst in russland
besser funktioniert
er liegt im deutschen interesse dass
zuerst die bürger dieses landes gedämpft
werden natürlich auf freiwilliger basis
jeder art von impfzwang auf den
indirekten lehnen wir ab
darum hat sich die bundesregierung zu
kümmern und zwar nicht aus im
nationalismus wie ein törichter vorwurf
sogleich lautete sondern aus derselben
selbstverständlichkeit mit der jeder
zuerst an die gesundheit seiner familie
decken aus demselben grunde wie sich der
bürgermeister von kassel eben erst
kassel kümmern muss und nicht um
bielefeld joe biden hat sich beim impfen
sofort an das motto von donald trump
gehalten america first und das ist
richtig so meine damen und herren auch
bei den corona maßnahmen werden wir am
ende wieder da stehen und feststellen
dass alles wünschen nicht geholfen an
freunden wir uns langsam mit dem
gedanken an das lockt bei uns wenig bis
nichts bewirken
intelligente hygiene konzepte bewirken
etwas man kann großveranstaltungen
absagen aber man kann nicht verhindern
dass menschen ein soziales leben führung
es liegen derzeit drei internationale
studien zur wirksamkeit eines lockt
downs auf die senkung der
infektionszahlen vor keine kommt zu dem
ergebnis dass es eine eindeutig messbare
wirkung gibt
der epidemiologe john joannidis
professorin standort hat die
auswirkungen von lok downs verschiedener
härte in 14 europäischen ländern und den
usa ausgewertet
sein fazit die maßnahmen haben sich
gering bis überhaupt nicht auf die
infektions kurve ausgewirkt
in schweden verläuft die kurve parallel
zu unserer das heißt die dynamik der
pandemie schert sich offenkundig nicht
darum ob das öffentliche leben herum
gefahren wird oder nicht noch keine
studien gibt es über die
kollateralschäden der korona maßnahmen
diese schäden betreffen nicht allein die
wirtschaft isolation kontakt
bewegungsmangel aussichtslosigkeit das
ständige aufeinander hocken in den
familien das alles schädigt die
gesundheit tausender bürger die
auswirkungen auf die psyche die bildung
und intelligenz der kinder sind massiv
der bundestag sollte deshalb einer
enquete kommission einsetzen die diese
schäden untersucht
gerade in hinblick auf die kommenden
partien sollten wir wissen mit welchem
einsatz wir spielen denn auf dauer meine
damen und herren verzeihen die bürger
einer regierung eben nicht dass sie fast
alles falsch gemacht hat
wir könnten auch aus dem was geschehen
ist lerne ich bedanke mich
[Applaus]